Hello everybody, Dr. Kevin Conner's in answering your most important questions that people have.
This is a good one.
How long is it going to take to get better?
How long is it going to take for this alternative stuff to kick in?
How long is it going to take for my cancer to start shrinking?
How long is it going to take for me to see results in the CT scan or my blood tests?
That's a great question.
It wants to know that.
I mean, you're doing this alternative stuff to hopefully have some good results.
That's what our goal is, right?
So how long does it take the rife to start working?
Understand that what you're doing with us is not just the rife.
It's a combination of a lot of things that we're doing.
We're trying to hit this disease process at as many as many of the sides of the facets
of the diamond that we possibly can.
So the rife, remember, is a tool just like any other tool, just like your nutrition is a
tool, chemotherapy is a tool, other therapies, IVs and PEMFs and things like that, they're
just tools.
I personally think the rife is one of the best tools as far as dealing with cancer, to
stimulate your immune system to attack the cancer, but it takes some time.
So you have to give it some time.
So we've had comments from people like, oh, I've been using this and I don't see any changes.
Well, you've only been using it for a couple of weeks.
You have to give it a couple of months before you're really going to see some changes.
But we have to be reasonable too, if you've been using it for six weeks and you're sliding
down the wrong way on the hill, we need to revisit it.
So don't feel bad about reaching out to us.
So we're here for you.
You need to reach out to us if you're fearful, if you're scared about anything, if you feel
like things are right, you were here for you, we're not on my way or the highway type clinic,
we're here to serve you.
That's what our purpose is.
And remember, it's a lot of things that we're doing.
So make sure that you check other things, make sure you're taking your nutrition, make
sure you're dealing with things that are going on between your ears too.
A lot of stress and anxiety, all that does is stimulate sympathetic tone and it's going
to decrease your immune response.
So we can do all the rifing that's possible.
Remember, what the rif doesn't hits the cancer at its own frequency.
So your immune system can better kill it.
Well, if your immune system is being suppressed by your inner anxiety, it's really hard to do
that job.
So if you need to get some counseling, you need to talk to a pastor, you need to get some
professional help to deal with maybe some fears and anxiety or some past emotional trauma,
please don't be too proud to reach out and do that.
That's what this path is for.
We're here to talk to you too.
So if you need help in that area, we're here to talk to you though.
We're not trained professional counselors.
We can love you and guide you and push you in a different direction, which may be very helpful,
but don't feel bad about needing that help in that area too.
We don't want to do anything.
Have you been doing anything that's suppressing your immune system?
The biggest thing that I struggle with with my patients is that some people are too proud
to reach out to us.
Don't do that.
We're here for you if you need to talk.
If you need somebody just to pray with, we're here to retest you.
If things aren't going the direction that we want them to go, we're here to tweak things.
If we need to tweak the frequencies and most of all, we're here to pray for you and with
you, we're always available for that.
So don't feel bad about reaching out.
We want you to.
That's what we're here for.
So how long does it take to get better?
Well, the honest truth is not all of us are going to get better.
So I might be better and in remission for months or longer and then maybe you're listening
to this video and I'm not even here anymore.
But we know that we're here for a reason here to be a blessing to other people.
We're here to to minister to other people and we're here to bring glory to God.
And I'm not saying we just as a clinic, I'm saying this with your purposes too.
So the more you can find that purpose in your life, the more that you can see that blessing
even in the disease, even in the struggles that you're going through right now, you can
see that you have a purpose in this to bless other people.
And that's really what is going to where you're going to really find that piece of God
that really transcends all understanding and it is beyond human conception.
And that's what our desire is for you.
And that's only found through prayer.
I know we want solid answers to and make our questions quantitative.
So how long is this going to take?
We don't know.
Those answers are only known by God.
We just our role is to do everything that we can.
Our role, you as the patient and us as the clinic to help come beside you to do everything
we possibly can, then ultimately we have to get to the point that the results are in God's
hands.
Matter of fact, the truth is the results were actually ordained by God before the foundations
of the earth were set.
And if we could understand that bigger picture like that, that could help take a lot of anxiety
out of our life.
So not maybe we won't be asking that question how long as often anymore, we'll start asking,
okay, Lord, how can I be a blessing to others in this?
And how can you use me in my struggle, in my weakness, in my disease, in this cancer?
How can you use me to bring you glory by maybe being a blessing to somebody today?
Show me who that can be, who I can be a blessing to today.
Those are the better questions that I want us to ask, all of us that I want to ask.
I don't always ask those questions, and nor do you, but we need to encourage each other to
start thinking that way.
That's what's going to help us grow in our relationship with God and help us understand
that all our circumstances are ordained for us for a reason.
And we need to be asking God what that reason is and how we can bring him glory through it.